[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce premier numéro de paf
2022 nous allons feuilleter ensemble
l'album de cette année qui s'ouvre dans
plusieurs domaines avec des invités
prestigieux qui ont accepté de
participer à cette émission va parler
santé avec le professeur djillali annane
qui est le doyen de la faculté de
médecine de versailles saint quentin on
va parler d'idées avec pierre henri
tavoillot qui est philosophe et qui
préside le collège de philosophie de la
sorbonne on va parler politique avec
stéphane rousseau professeur de droit
ancien doyen de la faculté de droit de
versailles saint quentin et puis on
parlera aussi des 400 aux molières en
matière de culture avec un des écrivains
qu'il connaît le mieux qui est
christophe maury qui est son biographe
et qui est le grand spécialiste de
molière et puis en fin d'émission
parlera aussi de numérique et d'économie
avec deux invités virginie fév et qui
est fait de la formation sur le
numérique et le journaliste de tv 78
nicolas landry avec lequel ben nous on y
apprend les grands chiffres de
l'économie de 2022 voilà donc une
émission vous pouvez consommer comme
vous le souhaitez soit par tranches par
sujets d'intérêt soit dans son
intégralité et on commence tout de suite
avec le sujet qui nous préoccupe et qui
vous préoccupe tous la santé
[Musique]
on va parler de santé avec le professeur
dit la vie un âne qui est chef du
service de réanimation de l'hôpital
raymond poincaré à garches qui te le
doyen de l'ufr santé simone veil d'une
université de versailles saint quentin
bonjour professeurs et bonne année
bonjour alors on va évoquer évidemment
le problème de santé est le premier
problème c'est en effet le problème du
virus avec sow mikron qui a marqué le
début de l'année 2022 qui se répand très
vite et qui peut-être moins virulent que
ses prédécesseurs
est ce que on a l'impression qu'on
laisse faire finalement et peut-être
pour aller vers une immunité collective
est ce que c'est ça apple calcul qu'on
pourrait avoir
alors c'est intéressant ce qu'on reparle
à nouveau dignité collective puisque il
ya quelques semaines quelques mois on
expliqué on ne l'attendrait jamais
justement tu fais des détaillants du
fait de la difficulté à déployer la
vaccination sur
l'ensemble de la planète
et donc cette notion même d'immunité
collective était profondément remise en
cause il y a quelques semaines à peine
ça veut dire quoi l'immunité collective
ça veut dire que l'individu qui n'a ni
fait la maladie ni étaient vaccinés
serait protégé par le groupe qui lui
aurait été ou vaccinés ou ayant fait la
maladie
dans la réalité comme la vaccination
malheureusement n'empêche pas la
transmission du virus et bien c'est un
facteur voiliers qui compromet cette
protection collective et on le vit
aujourd'hui puisque si omicron se
propage aussi vite et de façon aussi
massive alors que 91 % de la population
éligible en france est vaccinée c'est
bien la démonstration même que
malheureusement la vaccination ne permet
pas d'empêcher le virus deux circulait
mais où est ce qu'on peut dire quand
même que alors un effet on empêche pas
le virer de circuler mais ce qu'on peut
dire qu'elle elle atténue les formes
graves de maladie de façon générale
ça c'est très clairement l'effet
principal de la vaccination dans quatre
de lakovic 19 un effet remarquable
qui celui de prévenir les formes graves
et l'évolution vers les formes graves et
je faudrait dire aujourd'hui
heureusement on à 91% de la population
éligible vacciner parce qu'avec le
nombre de contacts sont quotidiennes on
voit qu'on aurait un nombre de formes
graves qui viendraient déborder de façon
massive les hôpitaux et malheureusement
se serait associé de décès considérable
on voit les stic a cité de la
vaccination pour nous protéger des
formes va justement ce mario qui est qui
se dit très très contagieux et n'a pas
immobilisé l'hôpital comme on aurait pu
le craindre
en tout état de cause il effectivement
il ne se traduit pas par une
augmentation massive en tout cas pour
l'instant
des hospitalisations en tout cas pas au
delà pas faire déborder nos hôpitaux
parce que l'attention sur l'hôpital
existe et l'attention sur les services
de réanimation existe aussi les passions
ils sont très nombreux il y arrive tous
les jours et on est quasiment à
saturation mais honnêtement encore une
fois ça n'est pas grand chose par
rapport à ce qu'on aurait pu attendre
avec le nombre de contaminations
quotidienne il ya plusieurs explications
à cela la première c'est que il est très
vraisemblable en effet que le variant
omicron soit moins pathogène moins
virulent au sens où il se développerait
davantage au niveau des voies aériennes
supérieures au niveau de la gorge du nez
de la bouche et atteindrait beaucoup
moins le poumon profond contraire en
pariant delta est donc engendrant mois
de pneumonie et plus d'infections orl ça
c'est une première explication la
deuxième explication qui est au moins
tout aussi importante c'est que le vario
mikron arribes dans une situation où la
vaccination est très largement déployées
et par conséquent les
nous les personnes nous nous avons une
certaine forme de protection à son égard
et nous ne sommes plus si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi vierge de toute
protection comme c'était le cas dans le
passé et donc c'est sûr c'est la
combinaison de facteurs qui fait que
heureusement omicron ne se traduit pas
par une tension excessive sur le système
de santé
quand le ministre de la santé dit brees
c'est peut-être la dernière vague est-ce
que vous pensez que c'est un peu
optimiste et qu'il faut plutôt
s'attendre à avoir comme ça d'autres
variant qui risque d'arriver et l'eau
faut s'habituer à vivre avec
avec ce virus à ses d'expression à la
droite bien évidemment parce que
scientifiquement rien ne laisse rien ne
supporte le fait rien ne vient appuyer
le fait scientifiquement parlant que ce
serait la dernière vague par contre
c'est là où je parle de maladresse c'est
par contre je pense que ce que voulait
dire le ministre sait que c'est
peut-être
le tournant de la pandémie dans le sens
où
on aurait mis fin à la pandémie pandémie
veut dire que le virus circule en même
temps dans tous les pays de la planète
et donc c'est cette étape là qui
pourrait être terminée en 2022
le virus ne disparaissant pas de la
terre mais grâce à l'immunité engendrés
par omicron et bien après omicron on se
retrouverait avec des foyers
épidémiques dans certains pays mais pas
en même temps et on ne serait plus en
phase pandémique ça c'est quelque chose
de probables je pense que c'est ce que
voulait dire le ministre en disant que
c'était la dernière vague alors au delà
de la crise à laquelle vous faites face
d'ailleurs tant qu en tant que médecin
mais il ya aussi tout ce qu'on a appris
de cette crise sanitaire il ya d'abord
la situation de l'hôpital vous même vous
avez été conseiller admise de de la
santé
est ce que est ce que cette crise inter
risque de nous faire changer notre
regard au fond sur les priorités en
matière de santé en tout cas il
faudrait ce que l'on peut dire c'est que
si on se souvient
mai juin 2020 après la première vague
ça a été le discours un discours assez
consensuel est assez général là on a
compris et on a compris qu'il était
temps de moderniser le système de santé
en particulier en france parce que c'est
un système de santé qui était basée sur
la notion qu'il n'y aurait plus jamais
en europe et en france en particulier
d'épidémie ou de maladies infectieuses
pouvant entraîner un tel problème au
sein de la société on était convaincu
qu'il fallait organiser le système de
santé pour traiter un cancer pour
traiter les maladies neurodégénératives
et que l'on n'avait pas à se soucier
comme avait plus à se préoccuper de ce
type de menace donc ça il faut
impérativement que l'on modifie les
choses qu'on reprenne ce discours parce
que il est clair que nous devons tout
faire pour renforcer la part de
l'organisation du système de santé
consacrée à la prévention c'est à la
fois et ça ça nécessite plusieurs
actions importantes ça nécessite d'abord
un investissement massif dans la
prévention plutôt que dans les
structures de soins ensuite ça nécessite
de modifier considérablement la
formation des futurs soignants mois et
dans ma formation et dans ma faculté
dans la formation des jeunes
professionnels la part de la prévention
est extrêmement modeste par rapport à la
part du traitement des maladies établi
pour ça aussi c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut profondément changé et repenser
considérablement l'organisation de notre
système de santé et la formation des
soignants et ça ça prend du temps
absolument ça prend du temps formation
au désir belle rage autour des médecins
aux sablons la formation ses 11
absolument et puis en plus la question
n'est pas de mon point de vue numérique
elle n'est pas au nombre
l aujourd'hui on a formé on forme des
médecins et des infirmières et des
kinésithérapeutes vraiment en nombre
très insuffisant par contre c'est leur
distribution
l'organisation encore une fois de
l'offre de l'offre de soin qui est
aujourd'hui inapproprié aux
problématiques de santé de notre société
et de celles qui vont venir dans les
prochaines dans les prochaines années
donc c'est moi le nombre de soignants
informé que l'exercice de leur métier la
façon dont ils exercent et dont on nous
exerçons notre métier et l'éco système
dans lequel nous exerçons notre métier
la deuxième leçon qu'on a appris ce faux
de cette crise c'est la formidable
intelligence et créativité des
chercheurs avec cet arn messager qui est
arrivé alors qu'il était recherché
depuis quelques années mais enfin c'est
la leyre voilà la rapidité avec laquelle
on a trouvé une réponse quand même et ça
c'est absolument admirable quand même
absolument et ça pour moi ce qu'on a ce
que le grand public a découvert ce qui
était mis en lumière ici c'est vraiment
la notion de science sans frontières
c'est à dire que face à un problème de
l'humanité l'ensemble des scientifiques
à la fois du monde académique mais aussi
du monde industriel des structures
privées se sont alliés derrière une
cause commune avec un partage inédit de
donner un partage inédit d une
mutualisation inédite de moyens et des
investissements considérables et tout ça
a fait que cette alliance du monde
scientifique pour lutter contre l'ennemi
qu'était le virus a permis c'est s'est
avancée absolument inédite c'est
incroyable que en deux ans à peine on
ait réussi à développer non pas un
vaccin mais plusieurs axes à deux
technologies différentes
et qu'on ait pu développer des
médicaments
dirigée contre la maladie et contre les
différentes étapes de la maladie c'est
vraiment inédit ça ne s'est jamais
produit avant en médecine
même pour le sida le sida ça a pris dix
ans
d'engagement pour développer les
premières thérapeutique ici en deux mois
on a développé tout un arsenal de 13 ans
deux enfants ça veut dire que vos faux
je voudrais leur garde et du médecin que
vous êtes sur cette année 2022 on peut
être relativement optimistes font mal
gré mal gré des difficultés il faut être
optimiste parce que encore une fois on a
sur le plan médical et sanitaire on a
toutes les raisons de l'être
on connais très bien je ne dis pas ça va
être la fin de la pandémie de l'épidémie
ce qui est certain c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on connaît très bien la maladie on est
capable de prendre en charge les
patients des coups pas capables de
prévenir donc il y a du point de vue du
contrôle de lakovic 19 on est dans une
situation où l'on peut être sera on a
beaucoup comme vous l'avez dit appris à
la fois sur nous sur nos systèmes sur
notre société l'organisation d'un
système de santé et je suis convaincu
que les efforts collectifs vont être
faits pour que pour donner un nouvel
élan à
la santé au système de santé en france
renforçant encore sa base puisqu'il est
fondé sur la solidarité
merci beaucoup pour s'est redit dalian
année et bonne année
bonne année également merci beaucoup
[Musique]
on va parler maintenant idées avec
pierre henri tavoillot bonjour
vous êtes vous êtes philosophe vous
enseignez à la sorbonne à sciences po
votre dernier livre dont nous avions
d'ailleurs parlé ici s'appelle la morale
de cette histoire c'est paru chez chez
michel lafon et puis vous présidez le
collège de philosophie de la sorbonne et
c'est d'ailleurs dans ce collège de
philosophie qui a eu lieu le vendredi et
samedi deux premiers vendredis samedis
de janvier un colloque sur le thème
après la déconstruction
reconstruire les sciences et la culture
alors pour être très clair je reprends
la fera de présentation de ce colloque
sur le site du collège de philosophie la
posséder coloniale aussi nommé au bouc
ou quand cette culture représente un
défi pour le monde éducatif alors avant
d'essayer de comprendre ce défi il faut
qu'on essaie de définir ses mots qu'est
ce que c'est la posséder connaître le
nialé qu'est ce que c'est lebouc
alors d'abord c'est un certain nombre de
phénomènes que l'on voit pas seulement
d'ailleurs dans le monde universitaire
mais qui sont très présents dans le
monde universitaire ces phénomènes qu'on
voit notamment qu'on perçoit que des
statues sont déboulonnés
quand on entend l'idée qu'il faudrait
des genres et des cours de récréation
pour faire en sorte que voilà les
discrimination entre les sexes existent
donc il ya toute une série de phénomènes
dans la société dont on peut dire qu'ils
nous viennent pour une large part des
états unis mais on voit aussi émerger en
france qui témoignent du fait qu'il ya
une sorte de pression voire de
moralisation sur un certain nombre de
comportements et puis dans le monde
académique on identifie aussi un certain
nombre de cas par exemple des
conférences qui sont perturbés voire
parfois interdite parce que précisément
ils ne représenteraient pas sur un
certain nombre de thèmes notamment les
questions de deux rapports alors la race
qui revient d'ailleurs la formule est
d'ailleurs intéressante par rapport au
genre par rapport à a éventuellement
d'ailleurs aussi des questions
d'écologie radical qui viennent et qui
constitue une sorte de pression et de
moralisation des débats avec des choses
qu'on peut dire et puis des choses qu'on
n'a pas le plus le droit ou pas le droit
de dire ou pas le droit d'ailleurs de
discuter donc ça c'est le contexte
social c'est ça non il ya aussi un
mouvement intellectuel
alors après tous inquiété des inégalités
des inégalités qui qui qui perdure c'est
tout à fait légitime ce qui vous
préoccupe me semble-t-il c'est que au
nom de cette lutte contre contre les
inégalités ont introduit une une sorte
d'ordre moral 1 je vous cite
incompatible avec nos principes
d'universalisme et de laïcité c'est ça
qui nous inquiète oui c'est ça c'est à
dire en fait pouvons être prendre un
tout petit peu de recul pour ça qu'on a
appelé ce colloque après la
déconstruction parce que la
déconstruction est un mouvement
intellectuel qui est d'ailleurs très
puissant et très profond on peut
identifier
en fait trois âges de la déconstruction
ou bien pour bien donné le contexte à
voir et à 2 pertinement est ce qu'il ya
nous sommes de plus dit parce que la
déconstruction ça fait partie de
l'histoire des des ide et la philosophie
oui on peut le dire même que c'est toute
la philosophie moderne jaillir des
cartes quand ils pratiquent sans doute
radical
dont la situation est très simple qui
voit là j'ai appris beaucoup de choses
en matière de théologie puis je suis un
peu perdue donc je vais pratiquer ce
qu'il appelle le doute c'est à dire
l'idée que je vais douter de tout donc
c'est une forme de déconstruction
jusqu'à ce que je trouve quelque chose
de de certains sur laquelle je puisse
reconstruire l'édifice des sciences et
c'est cette petite chose certaine tout
le monde la connaît ça fait partie de la
culture de base c'est je doute de quoi
puis-je ne pas douter c'est du fait que
je doute si je doute je pense et si je
pense eh bien je dis voilà fameux cogito
et bien sûr ce cogito il reconstruit
ensuite l'édifice des sciences pour
qu'on voit ici une première âge de la
déconstruction qui est un âge où on
déconstruit pour construire et rapport à
des choses qui nous paraissent infondées
crd notamment les dogmes théologique
c'est à dire les vérités révéler des
vérités qui ne sont pas produites par
les hommes ça c'est le premier âge la
déconstruction il ya un deuxième âge qui
commence avec schopenhauer et avec
nietzsche lui aussi très intéressant et
très puissant dans l'histoire de la
pensée qui consiste à faire à appliquer
cette méthode de la déconstruction cette
méthode de l'esprit critique sur les
vérités humaine elle-même c'est-à-dire
sur le vrai humain sur le beau sur la
science sur la morale nietzsche définit
sa manière de philosopher comme
philosophie avec le marteau et faut
déconstruire les idoles ce qu'on croit
en fait on y a une histoire n'y a pas
d'absolu dans la personne humaine
pourquoi fait il ça il fait ça parce
qu'il considère que ces idées nous
empêche de vivre pleinement sa c'est
l'argument de nietzsche il est repris
par fred qui consiste à dire que pour
lui ses idées
humaine nous empêche masque en quelque
sorte des conflits psychiques elle est
reprise aussi par marx à certains égards
qui consiste à dire que toutes ces idées
même les droits de l'homme les choses
comme ça nous empêche de voir les
conflits entre les classes les luttes
des classes il reprit aussi par
heidegger qui consiste à dire que toutes
ces idées cette rationalité nous empêche
de percevoir au fond la vérité de l'être
ce qu'ils appellent pour heidegger
l'être lui-même donc voilà il faut
déconstruire ça c'est pour dire l'esprit
critique c'est absolument nécessaire
mais à chaque pour arriver à quelque
chose qui reconstruit
simplement après il ya un troisième âge
voilà ce troisième âge on peut le faire
débuter avec ce qu'on appelle la pensée
68 c'est à dire des princes française et
ridha croco bourdieu qui eux pour une
part reproduisent ça mais avec l'idée
qu'il faut déconstruire pour se
déconstruire déconstruire pour
déconstruire et ça ça arrive tout en
effet à ce qu'on peut appeler la pensée
walk ou la pensée je vais essayer de
définir la pensée déconstructionniste
intersectionnelle ces démocrates ont
beaucoup alors je veux on peut la
qualifier définir ce cette idée en cinq
ans quatre grandes idées pour aller vite
l'idée 1 toute la société c'est un
rapport de domination des hommes ce qui
est c'est vrai que domination les
relations de femmes au fond c'est la
domination des hommes sur les femmes les
relation à la nature c'est la domination
du productivisme et du capitaliste sur
la nature les relations entre les races
c'est la domination de la race blanche
sur les autres roja ce même si le terme
de race et on le sait problématique du
conduite biologique donc au fond on a
des lunettes qui nous permettent de
regarder le réel uniquement à partir de
l'idée de domination tout et domination
et ce qui n'est pas domination n'existe
pas ça c'est la première idée à partir
de là le comble de la domination pour
cette pensée justement et colonial c'est
le colonialisme occidental
c'est pour ça que c'est une pensée très
anti occidental il faut la colonisation
c'est le comble de la domination
humaines de l'homme sur la femme du nord
sur le sud de la technique sur la nature
et c'est donc cette coupe
troisième idée pardon je vais un peu
vite mais
la décolonisation
l'émancipation de la femme la
préoccupation de l'environnement sur
l'environnement tout ça ce sont des
illusions c'est de la poudre aux yeux en
fait la domination est toujours là et
peut-être beaucoup plus sournoise et
puissante qu'elle n'a jamais été par le
passé donc en apparence les femmes sont
libres en vérité le patriarcat est
toujours là c'est ça l'idée c'est parce
que je défends c'est de résumer on croit
qu'on est voilà écolo parce qu'on fait
du tri etc pas du tout la nature est en
train de mourir sous le capot du coup du
capitalisme et donc à partir de là oui
le sentiment que la domination est
encore plus puissante aujourd'hui et à
cause de l'occident qu'elle n'a jamais
été alors on gomme la tue tout ce qu'il
a pu exister par le passé c'est à dire
le fait que les civilisations
occidentales est pas la seule à et
colonisé avoir colonisé qu'elle avait
été la seule eau dans toute l'histoire
de l'humanité avoir aboli l esclavage la
seule
et puis à partir de là je termine mon
raisonnement
face à cette ampleur de la domination et
là c'est tout à fait logique et bien
qu'il ya une seule chose à faire d'abord
il faut se réveiller et walk haute et
variées
cette domination n'est pas aussi
palpable qu'on puisse le pont qu'on peut
le penser mais ça suffit pas se
réveiller il faut annuler cansell
culture il faut impérativement agir y
compris quand on est un universitaire la
vouvoie le passage de la théorie à la
pratique il faut supprimer il faut
abolir les stéréotypes il faut lutter
contre tous et domination sournoise que
l'on ne voit pas et qui sont évidemment
absolument abjecte d'où le fait qu'on a
affaire là souvent en général mais pour
ceux qui sont pratiquants de cette
logique à des universitaires qui sont
devenus des militants qui sont devenus
des personnes qui veulent passer de la
théorie à la pratique et qui sont
parfois prêts à tout pour y parvenir
c'est ça c'est ce que vous dites c'est
que cette ce jeu enfin deux entre la
domination et l'oppression ne suffit pas
à constituer une
grille de lecture suffisante mais alors
les tenons enfin au fond de ces théories
vous vous répondre en disant que ba
rendre visibles les facteurs
d'inégalités de discrimination c'est pas
être idéologue
ça
c'est le point est absolument essentiel
simuler le point de clivage entre disons
les positions que je peux défendre et
puis l'évolution rock sais pas je n'ai
pas de domination s'est pas de dire qu'
il n'y a pas de choses quand d'alleuze
dans le monde qui a pas de
discrimination c'est l'idée de dire
qu'il n'ya pas que des disques in
d'ailleurs s'il y avait que des
discriminations à mon avis on ne
pourrait pas lutter contre c'est de dire
que nous avons des principes notamment
les principes démocratiques issues des
droits de l'homme européen
inventé par les par l'europe qui sont
des principes de justement
d'émancipation et que c'est pas en
détruisant ses principe d'une
anticipation qu'on va faire avancer les
choses mais c'est en s'appuyant sur ces
principes pour faire progresser la lutte
contre la discrimination à me faire
avancer la dénonciation des femmes faire
avancer la tension à la protection de
l'environnement c'est justement le fait
que de dire tout n'est pas domination
par exemple dans les rapports hommes
femmes est un truc qui s'appelle l'amour
et qui n'est pas de l'ordre ou
simplement de la domination de l'homme
sur la femme dans les rapports sociaux
il ya de l'amitié dont le rapport au
passé il ya des liens qu'on essaye de
comprendre ça s'appelle l'histoire
l'histoire rigoureuse et c'est pas en
déboulonnant la statue de colbert qu'on
va faire avancer la cause de la de la
condition des noirs dans l'histoire
c'est passe pas comme ça c'est au
contraire en comprenant ce qui s'est
passé par le passé en évitant toute
espèce de révisionnisme alors vous
l'avez dit c'est ce jour d'été des
dépenses et qui nous viennent des états
unis d y est peut-être d'ailleurs un
petit effet boomerang parce que vous
parliez de derrida de foucauld qui ont
été beaucoup étudié aux états unis qui
nous reviennent à un petit peu comme ça
en pleine face mais au four
c'est très bien de faire des colloques
comme ça mais on a quand même
l'impression que la france et
l'université peut-être aussi française
justement grâce au principe
d'universalisme kiki qui nous qui nous
fonde résiste assez bien quand même
assez mouvement est ce qu est ce qu il
aurait passé ou est-ce qu'il faut être
inquiet justement
ça c'est une question de vraiment
d'évaluation de la situation moi je
respecte tout à fait les gens qui nous
disent qu au fond c'est pas très très
grave que l'on a les ressources pour
pour lutter contre ça que c'est pas la
peine d'en faire un plat je suis plus
suspicieux à l'égard de ceux qui nous
disent souvent un raisonnement
extrêmement intéressant qui nous disent
1 le walkie ça n'existe pas 2 ça a
toujours existé et 3 ce formidable donc
voilà le raisonnement qu'on nous avons
ce qu'on nous oppose après c'est une
question d'évaluation de la situation
c'est vrai que là dessus il faut être
clair ce colloque avait vocation à faire
un état des lieux essayer de voir si
c'était effectivement on essaie d'abord
si on pouvait définir la
déconstructionniste pense qu'on est
arrivé à l'issue de ce colloque 2,6
était
potentiellement dangereux
je pense qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
témoignages dans des disciplines parce
que oui monde universitaire c'est
beaucoup de disciplines différentes et
donc on est difficile d'avoir une vision
d'ensemble donc là nous avions des gens
des sciences dures des gens donc
d'émettre titien des physiciens des gens
de musicologie des ans d'histoire de
l'art des gens de littérature jean de
philosophie et sociologie et donc voilà
on avait toute une série de témoignages
de personnes qui ont rapporté des faits
très très précis
indiquant qu on pouvait quand même d'un
peut s'inquiéter de la situation c'est à
dire que la montée en puissance de cette
idéologie constitue une pression qui
peut potentiellement mettre en péril la
liberté académique
et qui constituent une pression de plus
en plus importante même s'il faut
surtout pas en effet trop trop
dramatiser la situation et que nous
avons les ressources pour en france un
peu résisté c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
ce colloque a eu lieu probablement en
france et pas dans d'autres pays je 1,6
néanmoins sur le fait que ce colloque en
l'organisant en dehors d'un contexte
universitaire 6 2 c'est pas mon
université qui a organisé ce colloque je
n'aurais pas pu le faire dans mon
université les pressions ont été très
fortes dès lors que locke est apparu on
a eu quand même ses titres de noblesse
des communiqués des syndicats cgt sud et
unef pour dire que ce colloque était
scandaleux que vous m'avez pas de
légitimité à se tenir donc voilà c'est
quand même un indice du fait que ce
genre de choses et ce genre de débat on
ne peut pas forcément les avoir
facilement et nous prenons des risques
nous avons eu des internements d'entre
eux colloque qui ont dit écoutez votre
colloque est formidable mais moi je suis
en phase de recrutement à l'université
si je participe alors je suis mort
paru il ya d'ailleurs eu des
manifestations des étudiants on a
entendu le mot de phase i stem c'est à
dire très intéressant d'ailleurs parce
que il y avait parmi les participants
beaucoup de gens et de et de gauche de
droite des républicains quoi il ya
peut-être il n'a peut-être un je ne sais
pas qui a peut-être attirer ces
reproches et que vous aviez
appelé dans ce colloque c'est mathieu
bock-côté
est ce que oui est ce que qu'ils
apprennent quand même des positions
qu'il défend beaucoup zemmour et c est
ce que est ce que c'était une bonne
figure non parce que
c'est un universitaire d'abord il vient
et du canada et du québec qui est un
lieu particulièrement important donc
mêmes accords en avant-garde sur ces
questions s'est pas inintéressant de le
faire venir mais vous avez raison
d'indiquer que nous avions une diversité
à la fois disciplinaire et politique
totale j'étudie arrive à sa fin tu venir
parce qu'il était mais il va écrire un
texte dont les actes du colloque pour
lui j'ai vraiment faim je veux pas me
parler à sa place mais j'ai eu une
conversation avec lui au téléphone pour
lui ce que l'autre présente ça ça m'a
beaucoup ému dans ce sens à un acte
refondateurs de la gauche voyez donc de
dire que ce sont des fascistes et des
conservateurs ou des réactionnaires qui
ont noué le colloque saignée que si l'on
à 50 50 il y avait des représentants de
la droite de toutes les droites et des
représentants de je dirais pas toutes
les gauches parce que effectivement
embaucher la gauche extrême n'était pas
présente mais je l'avais bricage laïque
enfin voila tu étais qui étaient étaient
de très près avec des personnalités des
pointures sur le plan académique
j'ajoute par ailleurs que ce colloque
dont les enregistrements sont
disponibles donc chacun dans ce faire
wie a été vraiment d'un très très haut
niveau passionnant chacun souhaitant
donner le meilleur et avec des exemples
nous intéressant je pense notamment à
l'intervention d'alexandre gady
l'histoire de l'art et notamment une
statue de champ politique a été
critiquée au collège de france donc il
ya eu des moments extrêmement forts
extrêmement puissants dans ce colloque
est inquiète évidemment tous ceux qui
s'intéressent à ce sujet de d'aller voir
par eux-mêmes tout simplement alors il
ya pour conclure il ya cette
déconstruction dont vous avez parlé à
traverser ces mouvements de pensée et
mais il y avait dans le thème du
colloque la reconstruction alors la
reconstruction ça pourrait être quoi
alors bon là c'est un position
personnelle parce que je ne peux pas me
faire le représentant ici de tout le
monde mais signe de la reconstruction au
moins est justement de dire qu' il y a
dans les relations sociales aujourd'hui
des éléments de destruction on a fait de
domination et des éléments de
recomposition et c'est ça qui
m'intéresse pour personnellement c'est
de voir comment dans un univers réputé
individualiste où on nous devrions tous
être enfermés dans notre sphère privée
sans lien les uns avec les autres le
suspicieux ou indifférents les uns avec
les autres et bien notre univers
démocratique individualiste produit du
lien un indice
le monde démocratique les individus
d'aujourd'hui n'ont jamais été aussi
généreux il donne beaucoup d'argent
voilà générosité là d'un phénomène
impressionnant ne devrait pas exister
dans notre monde individualiste et
égoïste et plus ça va mal d'ailleurs
situation de kobe de 19 où la france est
dans une situation problématique et bien
au lieu que ça baisse ça monte encore
donc il ya là des ressorts qui me
paraissent extrêmement intéressant à
étudier pourquoi cet individu a besoin
encore envers et contre tous des autres
pour exister il a besoin de l'amour il a
besoin du lien social il admis rapport
au passé d'un rapport critique il a
besoin de projets pour l'avenir ça c'est
de la reconstruction
merci infiniment je renvoie en effet au
site du collège de philosophie où on
peut écouter les débats que vous avez
deux vendredis et samedis 7 et 8 janvier
merci beaucoup pierre henri tavoillot et
bonne année mais également de la
reconstruction de la structure merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
on va parler maintenant de politique
puisqu'il risque de se passer une ou
deux choses importantes au cours de
cette année avec stéphane son bonjour
bonjour patrice bonjour cher patrice est
vous êtes vous êtes professeur de droit
public vous êtes ancien doyen de la
faculté de droit de l'université de
versailles saint quentin alors on va pas
parler des résultats de l'élection
présidentielle bien que vous les
connaissiez déjà mais voulait garder
secret un oui nous inquiétez pas les
garder secrets je laissais de 4 avril
attention à la bulle mais on va on va
essayer de 2d d'analyser un peu ce qui
se peut se passer dans des prochains
mois dans la politique française d'abord
un mou peut-être sur cette élection
présidentielle au suffrage universel
voulue par le référendum voulu par le
général de gaulle c'est celle à
la l'élection la plus importante de la
vème république
oui absolument on peut même dire que si
vous laissez là c'est vraiment la clé de
voûte des institutions de la vème
république
qui qui qui à l'origine sont quand même
comment dirais-je reconfigurer en 1958
pour restaurer l'autorité de l'état est
très clairement pour reconstruire un
nouveau régime essentiellement autour de
la figure de la figure dominante d'un
homme donc c'est très lié aux
circonstances le général de gaulle donc
le principe même est décidé
en 1900 en 1962 général de gaulle était
lui en 1958 par un collège de grands
électeurs
en 62 les français sont favorables à
l'élection au suffrage universel direct
qui pour la première fois a lieu en 1965
donc
hélas il ya ya parfois on entend quand
même quelques contestations sur ce
système on y reviendra peut-être
derrière et sur cette élection au
suffrage universel mais on a
l'impression quand même que ça serait
très difficile de revenir en arrière par
rapport à ça oui vous avez absolument
raison
le système fait l'objet alors parfois à
juste titre de critique qui sont quasi
permanente et qui sont récurrentes
depuis le début
souvenez vous souvenez vous du banc fled
françois mitterrand le coup d'état
permanent qu'elle était très axé alors
non seulement sur la personne du général
de gaulle mais aussi sur 7 sur ce
principe de l'élection du président par
les français de manière directe
il ya eu quelques notamment de manière
assez récente quelque projet de vième
république ou n'est pas toujours
question de maintenir ce système mais je
pense fondamentalement alors il faut
jamais dire jamais mais que au delà de
tout ce qu'il peut être dit que les
français sont très attachés à cette à ce
système de l'élection directe du
président les français est en tout cas
une partie d'entre eux parce que alors
si on regarde un peu les les des études
chez des jeunes ils ont l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui les choses se passent
presque plus sur les réseaux sociaux que
dans les bureaux de vote et et
d'ailleurs il y aura même à cette
élection présidentielle qui pourtant
celle là laquelle les deux français
participent le plus une abstention
importante des jeunes le chef guido une
abstention importante de manière
générale c'est pas impossible je vais
vous dire que c'est probable je n'en
sais rien mais ça n'est pas impossible
une abstention plus prononcée du côté
des jeunes
j'allais vous dire là c'est un grand
classique on sait que les jeunes les
jeunes votent moins de façon générale il
ya quelques exceptions et on
pause cas ce qu'à ce scrutin qui aura
lieu dans trois mois les jeunes
s'abstiendront peut-être encore plus
mais c'est une illusion là là j'allais
dire la vraie vie c'est pas la vie des
réseaux sociaux la vraie vie c'est c'est
ce qui se passe dans l'arène politique
et dans l'espace public alors on le dit
et c'est là la clé de voûte des
institutions de la vème république il ya
un mécanisme qui ne s'est jamais démenti
notamment alors depuis l'inversion de ce
qu'on a pas le calendrier électoral
c'est-à-dire que des élections
légistatives suit l'élection
présidentielle c'est que les français
donnent une majorité au président qu'ils
viennent d'élire est ce que c'est une
règle absolue est ce qu'on pourrait pas
imaginer au faux que ben on revienne un
peu une cohabitation est ce que ça ne
pourrait pas ce que il ya peut-être
moins d'élan dans la dans la dans
l'élection présidentielle elle même
qu'il n'y avait eu par le passé oui il
faut préciser d'abord que sais tu
comment dirais-je cette inversion du
calendrier c'est à dire d'abord
l'élection présidentielle ensuite
l'élection législative
elle est justement était voulue pour
éviter les situations de cohabitation
c'est à dire situation les trois
épisodes de cohabitation chirac premier
ministre de mitterrand balladur premier
ministre de mitterrand et jospin premier
need de jacques chirac situation dans
laquelle le premier et d'un bord
politique opposé à celui du président de
la république pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
voulu éviter parce qu'on s'est aperçu au
cours de ces trois périodes que au delà
d'une espèce de pseudo équilibre de 2,2
d'équilibré des pouvoirs si vous voulez
à la tête de l'état au sein de la
dyarchie de l'état de la tête de l'état
il y avait en réalité une bataille
permanente entre les deux têtes
principal de de l'état donc est-ce que
c'est fondamentalement une bonne chose
que de cristalliser de cette manière les
élections législatives et de les rendre
dépendante de l'élection présidentielle
en terme d'efficacité
oui sans aucun doute en termes de
respiration politique en termes de marge
politique probablement nous et vous avez
raison rien n'est écrit après tout même
si ces deux scrutins
au lieu à deux ou trois mois
d'intervalle rien ne dit que le
président de la république qui sera élu
disposera d'une majorité solide à
l'assemblée enfin oui à l'assemblée
nationale pour autant est ce qu'il faut
j'allais dire revenir sur ce système ou
peut-être le nuance et
là encore n'en suis pas sûr il faut y
aller prudemment mais certaines
propositions qui consistent à dire on
pourrait instaurer des élections
législatives en plein milieu du
quinquennat au bout de deux ans et demi
après l'élection présidentielle pour
remettre en quelque sorte les compteurs
à zéro là je suis pas sûr que les
français ils soient prêts ça nous
rapprocherait sur ce point de la
démocratie américaine qui est une
démocratie alors extrêmement
qui est doté d'une très forte vitalité
puisque tous les deux ans il ya des
élections majeures qui se déroule entre
les midterm élections donc ça veut dire
qu'on est en campagne électorale
permanente ça je suis pas sûr que les
que les français ils soient réellement
prêts et les mid term elections comme
vous dites sont rarement favorables au
président l'appui bien sûr quelques avec
un système un système étasunien j'allais
vous dire c'est pas un problème parce
que le système est construit justement
sur 7 sur ses dissensions sur cette
tension dans notre système
institutionnel lui n'est pas configuré
du moins pas pour l'instant autour de
7,2 cette idée il ya un petit progrès au
problème même démocratique qui se
poseront voix comme il ya un
éparpillement au fond des des voix les
candidats qui se sont sélectionnés pour
le deuxième tour son art aux gros à plus
ou moins 20 % 1 des voix après
évidemment ils sont élus à la majorité
parce que ce où l'on vote contre le
contre l'autre candidat mais une fois
qu'ils veulent appliquer leur politique
et il se retrouve à sept joueuses de 20
25 25 % maximum ce qui est ce qui rend
compliqué à appliquer une politique est
ce que là aussi il faudrait pas
peut-être alors je sais pas si c'est une
réforme institutionnelle où une une
façon de vivre la politique différemment
mais faire en sorte que des majorités
plus vaste permette au fonds de
gouverner plus que ça ne l'est
aujourd'hui
oui sur le fond vous avez raison ça
m'inspire deux observations la première
pour signaler que la logique de
l'élection à deux tours telle qu'elle se
pratique en france pour l'élection
présidentielle c'est celle ci c'est
celle que vous avez décrite au premier
tour je choisis au second tour j'élimine
donc ça veut dire que l'essentiel du
vote du second tour c'est un vote de
rejet le vote du premier tour est un
vote d'adhésion mais la grande majorité
du corps électoral au second tour se
prononcent surtout par un refus un refus
de ce qu'il ne veut pas voir arriver au
pouvoir mais la seconde observation
c'est que votre idée de en quelque sorte
de coalition de de consensus autour de
formation politique plus large
susceptible de former une majorité elle
est ce système là il serait concevable
pour les élections législatives bien
entendu alors ce qui pourrait obliger le
président à négocier avant l'élection
met mais ce système là n'est pas
concevable
si vous voulez appliquer strictement à
l'élection présidentielle elle même
alors est ce que nous serions prêts
pour les élections législatives à ce
genre de quelque chose qui ressemblerait
à une une coalition à l'allemande par
exemple dans le passé on n'a pas été
loin on cite toujours 1900
1988 1991 michel rocard qui avait avec
l'aide de mitterrand d'ailleurs
nouer des alliances des alliances qui
sont affairés assez fragile mais ça a
finalement pas si mal fonctionné mais il
faut pas oublier que la france n'est pas
la vie politique française n'est pas
fondée sur l'idée de consensus elle est
plutôt
elle est plutôt la vie politique
française elle est plutôt fracturée
alors sans que la nasa n'a rien de
déplorable ni de désastreux la vie
politique fonctionne sur des fractures à
condition que les gens acceptent de se
parler de débattre je ne crois pas à
l'importation en france d'un modèle de
démocratie consensuelle tel qu'on peut
le voir ceux pratiqués en allemagne dans
certaines démocraties e du nord de
l'europe je crois culturellement là
encore nous n'y sommes pas vraiment prêt
sauf peut-être si la proportionnelle
enfin c'est un autre débat à alger et à
vous à la raison il ya ya ya ya autre
chose si vous parliez justement de cette
tradition française de la fracture la
vème république a été historiquement
vécu comme une fracture entre de la
droite et la gauche aura une coupure de
la france entre la droite et la gauche
2017 a été un grand changement puisque
ni les deux parties qui avait gouverné
jusque là n'ont pas été présents au
deuxième tour donc c'était c'était
c'était un total changement on entend
beaucoup de voix qui disent il faut
revenir à cette coupure droite gauche
alors d'abord ça pose un problème parce
que la droite on voit bien elle essaye
de revenir la gauche elle est tellement
divisée qu'on ne voit pas quelle serait
cette coupure droite gauche mais est ce
que vous pensez que l est
allez dire substantielle à la france une
coupure droite gauche ou est ce que on
est peut-être passé à autre chose avec
l'élection d' emmanuel macron alors
cessé c'est à la fois très complexe et
donc très intéressant ce que vous ce que
vous évoquez plusieurs observations en
premier lieu
je me référais aux travaux de deux d'une
collègue qui s'appelle janine mossuz
lavau qui est professeur émérite
maintenant a lieu près de paris et qui
en 2020 a publié un bouquin extrêmement
intéressant qui s'appelle le clivage
droite gauche toute une histoire et elle
elle montre elle fait la thèse suivante
c'est que
ce clivage droite gauche il existerait
encore du côté de la demande politique
c'est à dire du côté des électeurs mais
il existerait nettement moins du côté de
l'offre politique c'est à dire de la
classe politique la classe politique
elle serait passée à autre chose là où
le corps électoral lui serait resté sur
ce clivage droite gauche alors ce qu'on
peut dire cette thèse est pas
inintéressant
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que il faut
néanmoins la nuance et je suis pas loin
de d'y adhérer mais en la nuançant de
manière assez considérable au regard
notamment je cite un second auteur
majeur qu'est marcel gaucher qui
travaillent qui a beaucoup travaillé sur
cette histoire du clivage gauche droite
et qui démontre que ce clivage au fond
depuis 1789 et surtout depuis le 19e
siècle il a il a toujours été très
relatifs très évolutif beaucoup plus
qu'on ne peut qu on ne peut le dire la
droite d'aujourd'hui n'a presque plus
rien à voir avec ce qu'elle était au 19e
siècle idem pour la gauche et il ya donc
une relativité assez forte finalement y
compris du côté du corps électoral y
compris de ce que janine mossuz lavau
appelle la demande à gauche on admet
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus une sorte de
résignation à l'égard de la
mondialisation à droite j'allais dire de
la droite qui pour moi ma part est
fréquentable la droite parlementaire et
républicaine on admet beaucoup plus
aujourd'hui une forte tolérance à au
sujet des moeurs par exemple au sujet
des sujets sociaux
donc les choses sont beaucoup plus
nuancée quelle qu'elles n'y paraissent
et puis il ya
une autre un autre point qui est relatif
ça c'est du sondage met du sondage très
intéressant sur le sentiment
d'appartenance du côté du corps
électoral à la gauche ou à la droite ce
sentiment d'appartenance il est assez
fort du côté d'une part du parti les
républicains les les sympathisants du
parti des républicains ont une
conscience assez forte d'appartenir à la
droite et l'effort aussi du côté de la
france insoumise les sympathisants de la
france a soumis ils ont une conscience
assez forte d'appartenance à la gauche
en revanche ce sentiment d'appartenance
est relativement diffus relativement
faible ça n'étonnera personne du côté de
la république en marche les
sympathisants de la république en marche
et beaucoup plus étonnant ce sentiment
est aussi assez largement diffusé à
hauteur d'un tiers 30 à 33% des
sympatisants du côté du rassemblement
national d'ailleurs vous avez un tiers
des électeurs du rassemblement national
qui ne se situent pas qui ne se situe ni
à droite ni à gauche ça montre bien que
le duel entre emmanuel macron et marine
le pen échappent à ce cette construction
droit de gauche et cette construction de
rats de gauche dans ce dont je vais dire
dans ce dialogue mais dans ce duel
macron le pen il se reconstruit au fond
ce dialogue autour d'autres clivages
alors que d'autres clivages qu'on
connaît société ouverte sociétés fermées
souverainistes ou pro-européen
corps électoral des grandes métropoles
versus électeurs des pères des zones
péri urbaines ou des zones rurales il ya
un auteur anglais ou américains je ne
sais plus qui parle de du clivage entre
jambe n'importe où c'est à dire qu'ils
sont immergés dans la mondialisation et
peuple de quelque part qui sont très
enracinée dans des traditions dans des
cultures dans des lieux et c'est donc en
résumé je crois que ce clivage droite
gauche il produit encore des effets il
est encore malgré tout ancré dans
l'esprit
de beaucoup d'électeurs mais comme dit
edouard philippe la poutre est en train
de travailler et
alors ce clivage temps non pas à
s'effacer mais à devenir de plus en plus
réactifs ça c'est une réalité mais vous
savez cette évolution de toute façon
elle est lente et je je je pense qu'il
faudra plusieurs grandes élections
plusieurs grands rendez vous électoraux
pour qu'on sache vraiment où l'on veut
un dernier mot peut-être alors parce que
c'est un débat qu'on n'entend beaucoup
aujourd'hui sur celui des 500 signatures
puisque alors comme toujours parce que
chaque fois il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent on a du mal à voir les 500
signatures qui finissent toujours quand
même par les avoirs de 500 signatures
d'élus pour pouvoir se présenter à la
présidence de la république mais c'est
vrai que si quelqu'un est à + 10 % et
les sondages ne peut pas se présenter on
peut penser que ça pose un problème
démocratique est ce que vous pensez
qu'il faudrait changer cette mode de
sélection au fond des candidats
ce système il sait il est devenu un peu
plus sévère en 1976
1992 de 65 à 74 fallait 106 nature il
faut donc 500 depuis l'élection
présidentielle de 1981 et turcs roi il
ya d'autres contraintes 500 signatures
dont qui doivent être obtenus dans le
chalet dire dans le substrat politique
locale puisque c'est ce sont quarante
deux mille élus qui sont habilités à
donner leur signature lors les maires
les conseillers régionaux les conseils
départementaux les parlementaires donc
il faut une racine mans locale et puis
il ya des contraintes aussi assez fortes
sont pas plus de 50 élus par département
il faut 30 départements différents il ya
des contraintes chronologique et puis
depuis 2010 est il ya une nouvelle
contrainte c'est que le nom des
signataires doit
être publié
alors est-ce que par quoi ça justifie et
est-ce qu'il faut revenir sur ce système
où l'amendé ça justifie par le fait que
l'élection présidentielle
n'est pas ne doit pas être alors ça se
discute mais dans l'esprit actuel des
institutions ne doit pas être un forum
de discussion un forum de promotion de
certaines idéologies de certaines idées
de certains mouvements ça n'est pas si
vous voulez la foire politique qui va
permettre à tout un chacun de faire un
tour de piste pour se faire connaître
cette campagne présidentielle à une
fonction bien précise qui lui est
assignée c'est de désigner de concourir
à la désignation du président
ça n'est pas ça n'est pas en soi une
mince affaire est-ce qu'il faut donc une
fonction il ya un côté fonctionnel qui
est attachée à ses à cette idée des 500
signatures alors est-ce qu'il faut
revenir dessus
jeu de mon point de vue je ne le pense
pas est-ce qu'on pourrait l'amendé le
modifier le faire évoluer il ya des
propositions sur ce point il y avait
d'ailleurs une proposition qui avait été
faite par lionel jospin au moment où il
était premier ministre qui serait
de d'aboutir à un parrainage et hybrides
entre des élus d'un côté et des
signatures de citoyens de l'eau de l'eau
ce qui pourrait essayer ce qui pourrait
contribuer à essayer d'équilibrer les
ces deux pôles mais en tout état de
cause ce n'est pas simple mais sur le
principe en tout cas je suis moi de mon
point de vue favorable à ce qu'on
maintienne un verrou qui ne me semble
pas un verrou antidémocratique qui
confèrent une fonction bien précise à
cette campagne présidentielle de
concourir donc à l'élection du premier
personnage de l'état en tout cas jusqu'à
présent avec l'expérience qu'on a ça n'a
jamais empêché quiconque comme candidat
sérieux si je peux dire de se présenter
et même ya non il ya même des cordiers
shuweihat 2 candidats trotskistes à
chaque fois que qui a réussi à retenir y
assure bien quand même une diversité
très important
quand vous quand vous regardez
aujourd'hui dans la presse
le nombre de candidats qui se sont
déclarés alors vous en avez au delà des
des douze ou quinze candidats que tout
le monde connaît vous vous en avez
derrière vous en avez 20 ou 25 de
personnes
et qui sont et qui se disent candidat
alors évidemment il ya philippot il ya
les drouais l'ancien gilet jaune et
cetera il ya meilleur dire qu'il y en a
il y en a en tout donc ça doit tourner
autour de la quarantaine aujourd'hui
absolument donc voilà ce système des
signatures il introduit quand même une
part de révélations merci infiniment
s'était pas de mensonge et 6 passes
éclairage un plaisir c'était un plaisir
et bonne année et bonne année à vous
tous merci beaucoup
[Musique]
on va parler maintenant de deux cultures
et des 400 ans de mode ya ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que molière va
avoir quatre cents c'est pas rien mais
qu'il est toujours d'actualité la
fameuse phrase de guitry quoi d'neuf
molière est sur toutes les lèvres et en
titres de tous les artistes alors un
molière 400 ans et toutes ses dents
c'est vraiment ça on va parler avec
christophe mauric et décrivent un kit
homme de théâtre qui est un des grands
spécialistes de mode hier il a écrit
notamment la biographie de mode hier
chez folio et marquise la nouvelle
comédienne de molière c'est ballan
bonjour christophe ses bons jours
patrice bonjour à tous
il ya une chose qui frappe christophe
c'est que ya souvent des hauts et des
bas ces déchets des grands auteurs il
n'y a pas tellement une bâche et chez
molière et c'est une star et de ce
succès c'était déjà une star de son
vivant
oui absolument d'abord il faut quand on
voit le le l'inventaire après le décès
de la richesse de molière elle est
considérable il ya à peu près 60 kg
d'argenterie un clavecin il ya des
oeuvres d'art et mon père a toujours été
riche mollir a toujours couru après
l'argent et me lire a toujours eu
énormément de succès dès lors qu'il se
mette sous la protection de monsieur le
frère du roi puis du roi à partir de 758
donc oui c'est une star et on vient l'on
vient le boiron vient voir le comédien
parce que il fait rire parce que il fait
des annonces au théâtre en gesticulant
en mimant singes en imitant et tout le
monde s'y retrouve alors c'est une star
française mais il est aussi assez vite
connu en angleterre assez vite connu
aussi en russie ce qui pourrait paraître
étonnant c'est qu'est ce qui explique
selon vous justement cette universalité
du succès de bol hier c'est d'abord
l'inventeur vraiment de la comédie de
moeurs certes on avait une corneille
avait que le menteur la suite du menteur
et les autres comédies mais molière
avoir des personnages des comédies qui
sont à la fois le verre à moitié vide et
à moitié plein c'est à dire que on
affine et et alceste on a eu dans le par
exemple et on va avoir une comédie à
l'italienne je pense à ce cap 1 et au
personnage de mascaret qui reprend
harlequins on va voir cette comédie à
l'italienne mais une comédie qui
mettrait français finalement parce
qu'elle va reprendre les caractères
français
alors on va on va revenir voter sur
l'oeuvre après un peu quelques mots sur
lui souvent on en a fait quelqu'un qui
était comme ça un certain banque était
né dans un milieu pour pas du tout sur
un milieu bourgeois quoi dans le câliner
la famille poquelin est riche
elle est très artiste du côté créé c'est
du côté de la mère ou une pratiquement
tous les oncles et tantes sont musiciens
elle est
et le petit pot qu'havas est élevé chez
les jésuites au collège de clermont donc
au milieu des de la crème
social vous voulez et lorsque il quitte
paris en 42
présent d'été c'est le père qui va de la
caution pour le faire sortir de prison
il a été en prison que 24 heures au
châtelet mais mais qui va payer la
caution de dix mille livres ce qui
représente environ 110 mille euros ouais
d'accord donc oui c'est ça c'est plus un
milieu plutôt aisé est plutôt riche
parfois on en a fait c'est ça une sorte
d' enfant de la balle c'est pas tout à
fait ça qu'est ce qui fait qu'à 21 ans
alors qu'il avait fait des études
d'autres groupes de droite notamment
enfin qu'est ce qui fait qu'à 21 ans il
se tourne vers vers le théâtre c'est là
c'est la rencontre avec avec madeleine
béjart
indiscutablement il va il ya
certainement été passionné par le
théâtre depuis tout petit on raconte que
il traduisait les pièces de terence déjà
au collège de clermont enfin ça c'est un
peu de la légende et ensuite il va
tomber amoureux de madeleine béjart
alors les béjart ils sont nombreux
il ya le père et à la mère m'a réservé
il ya geneviève il ya le frère qui est
bègue et ils rêvent les béjart de de
jouer parce que madeleine à une très
grande ambition elle veut rentrer à
l'hôtel de bourgogne c'est à dire parmi
les comédiens du roi est parti quand
elle va monter cette troupe de théâtre
l'illustrent théâtre et on peut se
demander si molière enfin le jeune poker
n'est pas un peu le pigeon c'est à dire
que il a de l'argent donc on va le faire
des décors faire des costumes et puis de
changer à un jeu de paume en théâtre
tout ça coûte énormément d'argent et
cernes peu pour qu'un dit pas et
derrière donc le
madeleine est elle vraiment très
amoureuse de jean baptiste faut savoir
aussi que ll s'est émancipé dès l'âge de
16 ans qu'elle a deux enfants avec le
compte de modène et avec qui elle vit
avec qui elle terminera samedi
donc la place de pau cas là dedans et
liam je pense que les belges arlon un
peu prise prise en otage
alliaura madeleine béja il y aura aussi
armande
c'est la fille de madeleine
on peut dire ça un peu vulgaire mais
comme le dit très justement barbier dans
son joli livre le monde de molière pour
pour molière le sexe et la vie et donc
il va avoir une vie une vie sentimentale
et sexuelle extrêmement fourni alors
vous avez écrit une biographie d'un
formidable biographie de molière chez
folio gallimard folio
c'est pas facile d'écrire une biographie
parce qu'au fond à l'époque en a peu de
peu de données peu de documents ils ne
venaient pas de journaux ont raconté pas
tellement la vie des uns et des autres
c'est vrai que c'est alors comment
comment il est et molière ou est-ce
qu'il était plutôt côté il écrit ni
comédie mais c'est pas rigolo dans la
vie ici
alors non c'est un observateur c'est un
rigolo c'est un grand et très très drôle
quand il est en petit comité et quand il
est sur cet événement mais dans la vie
de tous les jours il est plutôt réservé
moi je le peux je compare un peu à
edouard baer vous voyez un type pas très
grands empires gars qui sourit qui fait
un peu timide comme ça et puis dès qu'on
relâche alors là il se lâche
adacore way et c'est vrai que il y a un
peu tout ce qu'on a dit mais je crois
que c'est assez vrai il ya un peu tous
ces personnages en lui c'est à dire
qu'il a à la fois le misanthrope tropez
et séducteur et la fois don juan et
sganarelle 1 il ya peu ça non oui vous
posiez la question des difficultés de
sources lorsqu on décrit une api de
molière en réalité tout est dans son
théâtre parce que son théâtre est très
autobiographique tous les personnages
c'est un peu lui c'est à dire cette
espèce de tyran domestique
ce sont ses travers et lorsqu'il dit que
il écrit des comédies pour corriger les
travers des hommes ce sont ses travers à
lui en premier et lorsqu'il fait sa
grande dépression nerveuse
burn out comme vous voulez en 766 il va
se moquer de lui même il écrit le
misanthrope et il se met dans la place
d'alceste alors on parlait de de
madeleine et d'armes au béjart la mère
et la fille qui ont été ses essais ses
maîtresses enfin et puis il y en a une
autre alors avec elle vous consacrer un
livre marquise la sensuelle comédienne
de molière c'est la marquise du parc
personnage époustouflant c'est à dire
que c'est une séductrice total est la
cdu absolument tout le monde
c'est la star c'est à dire que elle est
très très belle et on a une description
précise de son physique dans le mariage
forcé ou il parle de vos petits yeux
éveiller votre petit nez fripons vos
lèvres appétissant vos oreilles
amoureuse votre petit menton joliveau
petit et on roulait donc comme il décrit
le le le personnage décrit la femme qui
est devant lui on a donc cette
description précise du physique de
marquise du parc marquise du parc
s'appelle marie thérèse gaulle à son
père est italien et elle est à lyon et
elle fait un peu le petit singe à danser
autour
dieu l'âge de la charrette du père qui
vend des onguents d'accord et c'est
comme ça que
les
comédiens de l'illustré théâtre qui sont
en tournée à lyon à ce moment là la
repère et forcément ils sont tous
séduits par cette fille qui intègre la
troupe et qui va poursuivre le chemin
avec le avec illustre théâtre alors
comme buzz naturellement tout le monde
la regarde et tout le monde l'a relooké
tout le monde la dezir il va falloir
bien la marier parce que moins ça
évitera de dissocier les couples au sein
de la troupe et on va la mariée
ford et
c'est un type merveilleux gentil sympa
est ce que j'écris dans la biographie
romanesque comme vous ça vous vous êtes
présenté qui sort cette semaine
elle a en fait deux secrets marquise le
premier secret c'est qu'elle a de très
grandes oreilles elles traitent très mal
les cachent toujours et ça on le voit
dans la promptitude versailles où vous
avez armande naturellement jalouse qui
vient la voir pervers sont montrés moins
vos cheveux et elle fait ressortir les
oreilles et c'est là c'est pas écrit
pour rien cette histoire et puis la
deuxième chose c'est qu'elle ne sait ni
lire ni écrire que ça c'est formidable
et ça c'est le secret qui fait que c'est
berthelot qui va lui apprendre ses rôles
alors quels sont les rôles c'est pas des
grands rôles elle va jours ci dans deux
troisièmes rôles
oui donc imaginer elle va jouer la nuit
dans les aventures de diane elle va
jouer elvire dans ton gars yves navarre
une marquise dans la prude versailles
marquise elle même et puis elle va jouer
quand même arsinoé
dans que le misanthrope pourquoi parce
que la plupart des verts d'arsinoé sont
des verts de dont bercy de lavardens
qu'elle n'avait pas besoin de
réapprendre le texte d'accord alors
ensuite elle va trahir molière parce que
tout le monde la veut alors en 758
lorsqu'ils vont à rouen rencontré
corneille pour lui demander
l'autorisation de le jouer ça devait
durer huit jours ça va durer six mois
parce que corneille ne veut pas lâcher
la troupe tant qu'il n'a pas eu les
faveurs de
ses incroyables et va écrire ce fameux
sonné vague que dans le cône est
marquise un visage à quelques traits eux
à quelques traits un peu vieux souvenez
vous qu'à mon âge vous ne voudrez guère
mieux guerrieri et brassens a mis ça en
chansons avec la réponse de marc et j'ai
20 ans mon cher vaut mieux corneille et
je t'emmerde en attendant alors après je
vais renvoyer biographie parce que
malheureusement là on a on n'a pas le
temps de tout tout d'abord db c'est
formidable parce que c'est alors on
parle de corbeil et sûrs à 6 2 6 enfin
nous en principe est incroyable elle va
mourir en 68 d'un avortement raté
et tout le monde va croit que ses
racines qui l'a tué or elle il a créé le
rôle d'andromaque andromaque c'est pas
le grand rôle dans la pièce d'andromaque
c'est
sermonne et là on méandres max et comme
surendettées catherine deneuve si vous
voulez eux et donc est donc tout le
monde y va pour voir marty dedans alors
tous les mois c'est ce qui m'intéressait
dans ce dans ce livre dans ce revers
dans cette biographie romanesque de
marquise c'est que on comprend mieux les
rapports avec corneille
on comprend mieux les rapports avec
racine corneille qui arrive en 750
559 qui arrive de roanne qui quitteront
définitivement et qui signe un contrat
pour qui pour marquise et berthelot rené
pour qu'il vienne dans la troupe du
marais donc il fait encore un coup de
à molière et etc vient pas là
dessus mais c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles vous êtes un de ceux qui sont
persuadés que corneille n'a jamais écrit
comme on l'a dit les pièces de molière
mais bon je vous laisse passer
il a contribué à ben si chez ses marques
et oui mais le reste parce qu'après on a
beaucoup dit que molière n'avait rien
écrit que ces corneilles qui avait tout
écrit vous êtes de ceux qui qui ne pense
pas un mot
il ya un acteur très molière rien qui a
dès hier et crée le dictionnaire
amoureux de de me dire qu'ils francis
huster qui demande sa panthéonisation
pour le 400e anniversaire ça sera un bon
signe
écoutez ça serait formidable mais au
panthéon en dehors de voltaire et de
rousseau il n'y a que des gens d'après
la révolution française
commence à ouvrir à l'ancien régime
alors on va mettre jeanne d'arc va
mettre sully on va mettre colbert alors
là on va lancer des polémiques à chaque
fois donc le mieux c'est de garder la
règle le panthéon
au panthéon sont les grands hommes et
les grandes femmes la patrie
reconnaissante la patrie après la
république merci infiniment
christophe borie j'envoie donc à vos de
livre la biographie de molière
chef audio et marquise la sensuelle
comédienne de molière c'est chez balland
et puis il y aura beaucoup beaucoup de
dommages à molières sur ce territoire
notamment à versailles à saint germain
et vous retrouverez tous évidemment sur
le site de tv 78 merci beaucoup
christophe faurie merci patrice et bonne
année
[Musique]
on aborde maintenant la dernière ligne
droite de ce pass spécial 2022 on va
parler d'eux numérique et d'économie
avec virginie fév et bonjour je vous est
la fondatrice et la présidente de start
tap qui est une une entreprise de
formation au numérique pour les salariés
pour les entreprises vous êtes aussi le
trice on dit ça comme ça de stratégie
e-marketing
avec avec maylis bulk 1 2
racontez-nous en deux mots le livre
c'est un livre alors pour la petite info
je me suis formé avec micro application
à l'époque succès édité chez micro à
possible donc c'est un peu une façon de
rendre ce que j'avais avalé des données
voilà donc premières éditions 2013 donc
on en est à la quatrième édition ces 100
fiches pratiques qui permettent
d'apprendre le marketing digital et de
se poser les bonnes questions avec que
des cas pratiques c'est du conte très
pratique absolument très très pratique
et très concret et puis nicolas landry
bonjour bonjour profite à l'or va vous
parler vous êtes de rédaction de tv 78
on va parler avec vous d'économie ont
d'ailleurs commencé avec vous on va
essayer de voir quels sont les grands
chiffres qui peuvent nous alerter sur
l'économie en 2022 dans les points
difficiles les points positifs aussi
c'est ça et on va utiliser des chiffres
de 2020 et 2021 parce que 2022 c'est
difficile de prévoir la situation vous
voyez un la situation allait vraiment
très incertaine en ce moment avec
notamment le variant au micron qui ne
permet pas aujourd'hui aux chefs
d'entreprises de se projeter de projeter
des investissements de se projeter sur
leurs activités
la remise en place aussi du télétravail
dans de nombreuses entreprises à cause
de ce variant et de la reprise de
l'épidémie
et déjà des conséquences sur l'activité
des restaurants et des commerçants une
baisse un défi qu'elle cachait voilà il
ya des
conséquences sévices que les
travailleurs ne vont pas dans leur
entreprise et bien il ne consomme pas
ils ne vont pas mangé au restaurant le
midi et des chiffres qui nous viennent
de la ceppm d'île de france constate
qu'il ya déjà une baisse entre 20 et 30%
de l'activité des restaurants par
rapport à une activité normale d'avant
crise même le clic le click and collect
ça ne compense pas ça ne compense pas
parce que le restaurant forcément les
gens vont forcer sur place monge et et
donc il ya une baisse de l'activité qui
est notée par les restaurants d'île de
france et enfin la der le dernier sujet
c'est la question des prêts garantis par
l'état oui le ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire a déjà répondu à cette
inquiétude en annonçant un report en
tout cas un étalement du remboursement
jusqu'à dix ans pour les tpe qui sont
vraiment en difficulté voilà ce qu'on
peut dire sur cette année 2022 qui est
comme je disais incertaine est
difficilement prévisible
au niveau économique alors c'est
difficilement prévisible mais on va
quand même regarder un peu les
principales données il ya quelques
chiffres qui sont inquiétants ou enfin
sur lesquels il faut il faudrait
réfléchir il ya d'autres chiffres plus
rassurant sa croissance notamment on
commence peut-être par les films du des
défis économiques ses dires il ya
d'abord la dette la dette la dette post
co vide aujourd'hui la dette publique
française atteint 115 points 3 % du pib
ça a pris 18 points de pourcentage entre
2019 et 2021 aujourd'hui le déficit
public ça c'est une autre donnée donc
avait atteint 9,1 pour cent du pib en
cette année on abaissait ses 8,1 pour
cent du pib alors le déficit c'est ce
décalage qui peut y avoir entre les
recettes et les dépenses sur un an
voilà ça c'est les conséquences de la
crise et les conséquences de la crise
sanitaire l'état a investi massivement
pour soutenir l'économie c'est ce qui
fait que l'état s'est endetté mais
aujourd'hui l'état france et s'endettent
pour peu cher c'est à dire que comme
tout particulier ou comme toute
entreprise l'état paye des intérêts sur
ce qu'ils empruntent et au jeu donc en
2020 l'état emprunter sur dix ans a
moins 0,3 pour cent dia compte google ou
presque en empruntant exactement c'est
ça c'est que ça coûte rien à l'état
français est aujourd'hui le taux il est
entre 0 et 0,25 c'est vraiment très
faible et donc l'état français ben lui
ça me coûte rien en terme d'intérêt
d'emprunter sur les marchés pour sa part
dont c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
d'argent qui circule et il y avait
beaucoup de gens qui
kiffent financer les prêts d'état qui se
porte sur d'autres financements
notamment on en avait parlé bdnf t
l'avocat des nfd vient aussi de ce qui
abat il faut placer l'art en quoi bien
sûr l'argent prêté aux états ne rapporte
pas le vaut bien et c'est pour ça que le
marché des actions d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui le cac 40 atteint des
records puisque les particuliers ceux
qui veulent investir et ben
préfère plutôt les actions ou d'autres
produits financiers comme house rayonner
nft que les obligations d'état un
dernier mot quand même le grand positif
c'est la croissance
croissance record depuis les années 70
début des années 70 une croissance de
6,7 pour cent c'est une prévision on
aura le chiffre définitif au premier
semestre 2001 un peu plus haut que ça
serait peut-être plus au travail pour le
moment c'est prévisible les prévisions
de 10 6 points 7 % de croissance en 2021
alors que en 2020 on était à -7 9% donc
on voit que au timbre si c'est déjà fait
et le rattrapage de la cristalliser un
des enjeux autour de la dette ça va être
la question des règles européennes le
traité de maastricht imposé avant un
déficit maximum de 3% et une dette
publique de 60% du pib on va voir ce que
les dirigeants européens vont décider ce
qu'ils vont faire
9 alors on est à huit en déficit on est
à 8,1 pour cent au lieu de 3% et la
dette publique à la 115 3 % lyautey
cents au lieu de 60% donc on n'est pas
beaucoup et c'est vrai que emmanuel
macron qui prend la présidence de l'ue
veut faire revoir cette règle d'ailleurs
c'est une règle dans son montage abc
tellement pourquoi les cèdres dans les
conditions dans lesquelles elle avait
été adapté pourquoi 3% pourquoi pas 4
c'est vrai que c'était c'était assez
secret en 2d comme règle et c'est vrai
que à peu près tous les piles allemagne
il faudra voir parce que l'allemagne est
encore fait partie des pays qui veulent
respecter les règles budgétaires
notamment le nouveau ministre de
l'économie mais il ya probablement au
consensus qui n entre la france et
l'italie notamment
pour relever ce plafond de 3% et voir ce
qui peut être les différents au niveau
européen effectivement l'autre sujet qui
est pendant un peu de la dette c'est
l'inflation on le voit en 2021 retour de
la flotte parce que retour oui c'est
vrai qu'on avait oublié moi quand
j'étais jeune je me souviens vivant il y
avait des inflations 15% fin du temps du
temps de giscard mitterrand y avait des
inflations absolument énorme pour çà de
là on était habitués depuis quelques
années a très très peu d'inflation enfin
-2 1% quoi très peu d'inflation alors
que l'argent circule les banque centrale
a injecté beaucoup d'argent ces
dernières années notamment la banque
centrale européenne qui a injecté
beaucoup de monnaie sur le chose dans
l'économie et d'après la théorie cette
masse monétaire devait amener de
l'inflation et en fait on ne constatait
pas y avait très peu d'inflation ces
dernières années hélas en 2021 la france
donc c'est un chiffre de novembre 2021
'l'indice de prix de la consommation en
france et atteint 2,8 pour cent alors
c'est une hausse de l'inflation entre
2020 et 2021 due à un rattrapage par
rapport à la crise sanitaire l'économie
était à l'arrêt les matières premières
s'est effondré je prends l'exemple par
exemple du pétrole en avril 2020 il
était qu'à 20 dollars le baril alors en
octobre 2021 ses 80 dollars le baril et
4 x 4 à le prix et on l'a vu d'ailleurs
avec les prix à la pompe est vraiment
heureusement pas été multiplié par 4 mai
mais que beaucoup vont bientôt augmenter
donc il ya un effet sur les matières
premières et un effet aussi sur les
pénurie on a autant de l'auxois c'est
conjoncturel c'est vraiment
conjoncturelle alors il ya notre
inflation vin qu'on a pas d'infraction
l'inflation pardon structurelles taux
structurel et c'est par rapport à ce que
je disais auparavant par rapport aux
banques centrales qui injecte de la
monnaie sur dans l'économie qui peut
engendrer de l'inflation est là on l'a
vu ces dernières années la fed aux états
unis la banque centrale européenne a
injecté de l'argent sur les marchés en
rachetant des actifs alors pour faire
simple c'est à dire que les états
s'endettent la banque centrale
européenne pour maintenir les taux
auquel les états peuvent emprunter
rachète surnombre des taux de la dette
de la tête des états pour maintenir les
taux faibles et notamment la bce avait
mis en place un programme d'achat
urgence pandémie en mars 2020 pour
répondre à l'endettement des états pour
soutenir l'économie et d'ailleurs la
banque centrale européenne met fin à ce
programme mettra fin à ce programme en
mars 2022 mais par contre elle maintient
son programme de rachat d'actifs que
mario draghi ancien président de la
banque centrale européenne aujourd'hui
président du conseil enfin bien ma vie
mais du coup à l'époque en 2011 il avait
lancé ce programme d'achat d'actifs des
pays européens pour mettre fin à cette
crise de la dette européenne est
sûrement sauvegarder la zone euro
absolument donc oui c'est ça donc il va
falloir surveiller cette inflation parce
que qui dit inflation dit aussi
relèvement des salaires
il ya toute une chaîne qui se met en
place en cas d'inflation
le ballet de de la reprise donc les
entreprises vont un peu mieux elle
recrute alors got facilement non c'est
là où où c'est un peu compliqué pour
certains secteurs et certaines
entreprises c'est à dire que vous l'avez
dit la reprise elle s'est vu dès le mois
de septembre il ya eu une explosion de
la reprise l'activité est revenu mais
certaines entreprises ont eu des
difficultés à faire face et ont parfois
même refusé des marchés je prends deux
chiffres qui nous viennent a encore une
fois de la ceppm d'île de france en 2000
21 47 % des pme et des tpe
d'ile-de-france connaissez ce manque
d'effectif et parmi elles 50 3% ont dû
refuser des marchés c'est très rare
manque de c'est très simple voilà des
entreprises n'ont pas manque de
personnel manque de personnel 1 elles
ont démarché en face elles ont tellement
que doivent refuser certains marchés
parce qu'elles n'ont pas assez de
personnes au sein de l'entreprise alors
faut dire que le chômage a baissé
ce matin je crois de 8% environ 10 ans
qui est l'un des meilleurs taux enfin de
souvent japonais tournée qu'on ait
jamais eu mais pour ça c'est quand même
pas le plein emploi tout à fait c'est
vrai alain en place à partir de 5 % à
peu près 1 si on prend pas et donc
il faudrait savoir d'où ça vient parce
que certains disent et parce que des
gens préfèrent finalement ne pas
travailler
[Musique]
négation plusieurs problématiques avec
déjà une problématique de rendre
attractif le métier un métier prenant
d'ailleurs les secteurs qui sont
impactés par ces difficultés de
recrutement il ya le bâtiment la
restauration le service à la personne et
le numérique j'en ai pris quatre
longueurs aussi mais voilà le numérique
est aussi concernée pour différentes
problématiques on va le voir avec vous
qui vivez mais d'abord sur la
restauration le service à la personne et
le bâtiment aussi c'est une
problématique de d'attractivité de la
créativité salaire du métier se montrer
ou non les salaires sont pas très haut
d'ailleurs il ya eu des renégociations
dans différents secteurs d'activité et
aussi dans différentes entreprises et
puis c'est aussi les conditions de
travail si le travail difficile solo
voilà le numérique c'est une
problématique de formation clairement
c'est ça
effectivement les métiers évoluent et
plus en plus de besoins juste pour
d'ailleurs répondre sur la partie
chômage je pense que les dispositifs de
formation aussi contribué serre que
beaucoup d'équipés ont été mis en
formation ont été mis au chômage partiel
pendant cette période est donc
effectivement sur les taux ça doit se
ressentir aussi et quand on parle des
dispositifs maintenant de formation là
qui ont été mis en place
pour le coc vide et eu quand même des
plans de transformation numérique très
importants qui ont été déployés dans les
sociétés parce que effectivement on n'a
pas deux ans n'a pas de profils formés
de façon opérationnelle et que parfois
en termes de formation on n'a pas
d'informations on peut pas se former et
puis vivre sur ses acquis pendant dix
ans le numérique ça évolue très vite et
donc il faut se mettre à jour très très
régulièrement quand on met un pied
dedans soit finalement on démarre la
formation donc il faut des formations
très concret très opérationnelle est
toujours à jour quoi donc ça m'a saoulé
seulement voix sur 5 entendu il ya
plusieurs écoles je pense notamment à
l'école de 1600 qui a lancé une
formation en cybersécurité à montigny le
bretonneux parce que la cybersécurité
vérité est un des grands un jeu
dangereux dans parlera peut-être tout
aller avec vous mais c'est vrai que plus
le plus le monde se numérise que c'est à
dire plus la cybersécurité est
importante et il faut des compétences et
puis il faut j'ai appris que finalement
le numérique c'est ce qui a permis aussi
de maintenir l'activité on peut
maintenant je n'ai clients ligne on peut
communiquer et du télétravail avec vous
tout à l'heure avec elton en effet de
nouvelles données même si dans certains
secteurs comme vous le disiez ça peut ça
peut poser des problèmes
peut-être un mot quand même sur le plan
de relance et puis et puis cet objectif
qui avait été
défini par emmanuel macron la france
france 2030 alors commençons d'abord par
le plan de relance 100 milliards
l'hérault déployer
519 millions d'euros dans les yvelines
pour 198 entreprises bénéficiaires alors
d'entreprise voilà cent quatre-vingt
dix-huit entreprises alors c'est des
grands groupes médias surtout d un tissu
important de pme et de la dpee dans les
yvelines des start-up aussi et du coup
ça a permis de financer enfin en tout
cas d'aidé au financement parce que
certaines entreprises avaient un
investissement global
une part été financée par l'entreprise
l'autre par étaient financés par ce plan
de relance et par l'état
c'était ce sont des projets industriels
de modernisation des outils de
production certaines entreprises ont
relocalisé des activités qui étaient à
l'étranger partie et ont ramené
l'activité en france c'est aussi des
projets d'industrie du futur
d'innovation soutenue dans les yvelines
85 millions d'euros pour l'écologie avec
notamment de la transition
environnementale pour certaines
entreprises ou encore ce programme de
l'avion vers avec safran à 50 euros et
safran qui a passé un partenariat ça a
été annoncé en septembre dernier safran
a passé un partenariat avec total energy
pour développer un bio carburant destiné
aux avions vous avez parlé ensuite du
programme france dans trente 30
milliards d'euros sur cinq ans et là je
vais vous proposer de rester dans
l'environnement parce que c'est l'enjeu
c'est l'un des enjeux majeurs la
prochaine année d'ailleurs le président
ma république emmanuel macron annoncé 8
milliards d'euros sur l'énergie pour
développer l'hydrogène
pour les véhicules et le nucléaire donc
un maintien de l'énergie nucléaire en
france
4 milliards d'euros sur les transports
du futur avec
l'objectif de produire 2 millions de
véhicules électriques et hybrides
les chiffres viennent de tomber ce matin
dans les échos un bond énorme du marché
de l'automobile électrique seulement en
2021 donc on voit que oui parce qu'il ya
une enquête qui est tout à fait
passionnante qui montre d'ailleurs que
les français en très très grande
majorité sont reste attaché à l'auto
louis d'endosser leur dit il faut
arrêter l'automobile il reste attaché à
huile et en même temps ils veulent faire
des efforts pour l'environnement d'où la
doula faveur aux véhicules électriques
il est peut-être aussi un phénomène sur
les transports c'est qu'aujourd'hui
l'offre de transport elle est encore pas
déployé d'une telle manière à ce qu'on
puisse est totalement autonome même
quand on va à paris fin
je pense que ça doit embrasser pas
impacter ce qu'on va conserver son
véhicule et on a bien vu qu'elle quand
on a voulu prendre des mesures plus
restrictives sur notamment le poste pour
les quatre mâles ça a provoqué la crise
des gilet jaune
et très rapidement 1 2 milliard d'euros
sur l'alimentation saine durable et
traçable et 3 milliards d'euros sur la
santé et enfin 2 milliards sur le
spatial et des fonds marins oui dans
l'espace rabelais l'enjeu spatiale et
c'est intéressant parce que
d'importantes ici si on regarde au fond
c'est une une innovation totalement la
société à sa façon on va s'intéresser au
spatial on va s'intéresser à la limite
de notre alimentation va s'intéresser
avant l'électrique c'est vrai que c'est
c'est c'est aussi les changements enfin
appliquée par le est d'ailleurs gia le
réchauffement climatique de demain sur
le spatial on à ariane groupe e aux
mureaux dans les yvelines et l'autre
jour je me suis rendu dans une
entreprise
située aux loges en josas qui s'appelle
sérieuse parce qu'ils veulent développer
des lanceurs de satellites
réutilisables et donc ils sont en cours
de développement ils font leur test au
logement joseph et ils vont sûrement
faire une expérimentation
réel
dans cette année et produire les
premiers prototypes d'ici à la fin de
l'année et ils recherchent d'ailleurs
actuellement une usine de production il
cherche à s'implanter sur le plateau de
saclay donc encore une entreprise
innovante qui sera présente et qui est
déjà présente dans les yvelines puisque
vous en parlez je signale que le 24
janvier prochain et ici même avec avec
les légions de l'ue vs que vous fêtera
le premier anniversaire du lancement du
satellite de l'hiver lui qui était qui
étaient partis l'an dernier qui a été
lancé par elon musk enfin le groupe
d'elon musk et c'est donc va parler des
espaces de conquête spatiale et de
l'importance de l'espace dans le monde
qui vient virginie fév et on va parler
maintenant numérique avec vous
nicolas parler du télétravail
évidemment le télétravail c'est devenu
une donnée essentielle
et ça implique de pouvoir se former
d'être formé sa applique le numérique il
n'y a pas de télétravail 100 numérique
exactement déjà c'est vrai qu'il ya une
réglementation là qui est qui qui
obligeait d'entreprise finalement à
mettre quatre jours par semaine rythmée
salariés en télétravail c'est vrai qu'
on n'est plus dans justin télétravail
d'une ou deux journées par semaine vous
verrez que c'est c'est quasiment la
majorité du temps de travail
effectivement le numérique le numérique
qui ça joue sur plein de sur plein
d'aspects il ya toute la partie comme on
disait tout à l'heure d'aller chercher
des clients parce qu'on peut de moins en
moins les voir en face à face on peut de
moins en moins assuré des rendez vous
faut des passes il faut avoir son
passage à l'inter pour aller au
restaurant toute l'activité commerciale
est quand même relativement ralenti
c'est vrai que le numérique ça permet de
créer du lien de continuer à échanger de
continuer à capter des nouveaux
prospects rassurer aussi ses clients
existants ce qui est des vrais angoisse
qui se créent aussi est ce qu'une
entreprise d angoisse dans le dans le
télétravail c'est vrai il ya évidemment
la guadeloupe à deux pas rencontrer
c'est que ses collègues de bureau mais
savoir si on est équipé si on saura
faire il ya il ya aussi ça mais ce qui
est sûr c'est ce qu' il y avait il ya
une étude qui est apparue récemment
qu'ils montraient enfin 80 % des
responsables informatiques disait que
savait qu'on cible s'est
considérablement accéléré la
transformation numérique ce que tout le
monde a dû s'y mettre maîtrisez les
outils même de bazens et parfois même
les suites de base
bureautique on est maîtrisée pas donc le
numérique s'apprend en différents
aspects et puis ensuite effectivement il
ya tout tout tout cette façon de
s'organiser dans la gestion des mails
dans la partie communication dans le
stockage on parle également de sécurité
mais il ya une vraie
obligation de se former et d'accélérer
en fait une montée en compétences dans
le domaine oui l'importance de la
formation et
est ce que là dessus il ya des aides de
l'état pour les entreprises pour la
formation au numérique oui d'ailleurs
c'est un des axes prioritaires du
gouvernement donc il ya aussi bien alors
il ya déjà tout ou les fonds de
formation et la mobilisation des fonds
par les autres co qui sont quand même
assez important dans un pays mais
également le cpf on en a beaucoup parlé
de l' usage du cpf pour les formations
cbf c'est quoi le compte personnel de
formation tout le monde n'a pas activé
tout le monde s'est pendu alors moi j'ai
fait surprenant je ne sais pas c'est
peut-être en cdd des gens moi je
n'arrête pas de recevoir des sms et des
mails visant à activer votre compte de
formation je me dis c'est que c'est des
escrocs cd c'est vrai ça alors faut
faire attention à leurs gaffes
effectivement il ya quand même derrière
ça il ya eu beaucoup de détournements
des comptes cpf ya aussi enfin il
beaucoup d' arnaque dans le domaine et
puis certains se font passer parfois par
des organismes publics pour vendre les
formations et faire utiliser les fonds
en mettant des pressions en disant que
finalement faut vite vite consommé les
fonds on peut faire très très attention
et très vigilants
effectivement
ça à pousser de plus en plus les
entreprises ont poussé et finalement l
usage de la formation pour des périodes
où l'activité est au ralenti et donc
effectivement la formation c et
apprécions dispositif spécial c'est le
fn qui est quand même incroyable et dont
on parle très peu le fonds national de
l'emploi qui permet aujourd'hui de
déployer des gros plans de formation
pour accompagner la transformation
numérique de l'entreprise sur un an
déployer sur un an donc tout 2022 et du
coup effectivement c'est c'est quand
même assez exceptionnel au démarrage
c'est un c'était un fonds qui était
dédiée simplement pour les entreprises
en difficulté est là maintenant c'est
vraiment pour l'accompagnement d'une
mutation numérique donc c'est vrai que
ça permet de former toutes les équipes
et des faits remonter dans le domaine
donc les entreprises peuvent activer
leurs droits et se faire financer des
finances est absolument la formation
c'est très important et ça montre aussi
belle cette mutation des entreprises
vers le numérique qu'elle soulève les
questions puisque vous faites vous de la
formation pour les entreprises pour les
sonneries quelles sont les questions
qu'on vous pose le plus souvent que des
entreprises où les salariés vous pose
depuis souvent
alors souvent il ya aussi un problème de
base c'est pas savoir ce dont on a
besoin et s'y identifient clairement
quelles sont les compétences que j'ai
besoin dans mon entreprise il ya aussi
des secteurs qui
finalement au moins pris le pari d'aller
dans le numérique comme l'industrie qui
est finalement aujourd'hui dit encore où
tout le 'b to b' qui pense
qu'effectivement c'est encore pas tout à
fait approprié qu'il faut laisser ça aux
entreprises avec des biens de
consommation courants donc la première
question c'est quelles sont les
compétences dont j'ai besoin quels sont
les moyens que je vais y est à louer et
puis ensuite sur les autres questions il
ya effectivement on parlait aussi de
génération il ya cette angoisse de
savoir il parce que c'est des nationales
a bug est ce que tout le monde peut se
terminer la première question c'est est
ce que je suis capable de me faire aimer
parce que c'est dur est ce que c'est
lorsque c'est compliqué exactement et
puis on met tout et rien en numérique
c'est à dire que y'a codeurs qui sont
des métiers très technique et puis il ya
des métiers de marketing digital qui
sont community management animer les
réseaux sociaux ou rédiger pour le web
qui sont plus accessibles entre
parenthèses et qui doit s'apprendre
assez vite complètement et en fait c'est
vrai que et d'ailleurs c'est aussi une
un des sujets du gouvernement pour la
suite sur les formations dans le
numérique c'est pousser aux formations
opérationnelles
professionnels qui permettent d'être
très vite concrètement de pouvoir
désactiver concours très très vite en
entreprise
parce que le problème de toutes les
formations théoriques ou très longue
c'est que parfois elles sont très vite
obsolète doit la demande qui bouge sans
cesse donc exactement donc et donc il
faut très vite aller vers du concret et
du cas pratique quoi il n'y a que ça la
pratique on en dise est un mot tout à
l'heure évidemment la question de la
cybersécurité va être essentiel pendant
les dans les bras dans les années qui
viennent elle est déjà des dires il ya
beaucoup d'attaquants d'entreprise sur
ce territoire notamment ce qu'on appelle
des roms somewhere c'est à dire que un
pirate informatique va bloquer un
sixième d'un réseau dans une entreprise
dans un établissement public en avril
dans des villes comme les sanitaires et
donc le pirate informatique doit
assister dans les hôpitaux aussi way et
forcément quand un hôpital une mairie à
son système informatique bloqués et bien
le pirate va demander une rançon en
échange du déblocage des rançons qui
sont qui peuvent être énormes et
des alors en france on a l'interdiction
de payer une rançon informatique me
semble c'est une règle de l'inde si
c'est ça
qui est interdit de payer les rançons
informatique est pur il faut d'après le
système la question du déblocage du
système et puis ça évolue tellement vite
sa bonne fête finalement la
cybersécurité ça pas de faim dont
quelqu'un pour avoir créé le système
qu'il a sécurisé donc cette personne
enfin bref en tout cas les données sont
très vite accessible et c'est vrai qu'il
faut renforcer en permanence et et
l'enjeu c'est que parfois sur des choses
très commune en télétravail par exemple
ton stock non affichés sur nos
ordinateurs qui sont pas toujours
sécurisés on entre on partage notre avis
sur les réseaux sociaux on partage que
on est en vacances et qu'on est
peut-être responsable de quelque chose
et du coup on sait l'absence on l'a vu
d'ailleurs je crois c'était quelques
années sur le sur le monde quand il ya
un problème terrifiée et bien le
piratage où ils voulaient effectivement
on partage plein de choses des conserves
en vacances on dit qu'on est parti alors
pour pour les cambriolages c'est pareil
et donc c'est vrai qu'on se rend pas
bien le trouver dans les réseaux sociaux
parfois oui dans d'autres des brosses à
dents manquantes devraient pas donné
mais ça c'est les responsabilités de
chacun et donc c'est vrai que réfléchir
un peu au delà même de la sécurisation
du matériel et aussi toute l'information
vie publique et les prêts seront pas
compte de l'impact ou tout ces gens qui
font des fichiers excel de leurs mots de
passe qui se rendent pas compte et peu à
l'extérieur des cours de formation
personnelle ou peut-être un peu de
d'escroquerie j'ai l'impression que les
boîtes de cybersécurité se multiplient
et comme
l'a aussi vos bons il faut peut-être
faire attention avant de s'adresser à
une botte de cybersécurité il ya des
grandes entreprises il sera même
le territoire
on pense à airbus cybernation ciel
elancourt on pense à atos wii qui a
aussi son siège afin qu'ils incitent aux
clayes-sous-bois et après il ya des
startups elle prendrait ça veut pas dire
d'autre reste le petit ne sont pas
excellentes bien sûr il ya des six
dernières qui a été primée d'ailleurs
qui était aussi boxe absolument cibox
auxi box situé à guyancourt je pense
aussi à sidi comme si la qui est engagée
dans la formation en cyber sécurité
et saint quentin en yvelines l'opération
est aussi engagé dans ce domaine là en
proposant des formations avec des
collaborations avec des centres de
formation je pense rap up school je
pense à l'école de 1600 comme j'en ai
parlé tout à l'heure et c'est l'enjeu
majeur les compétences en cybersécurité
quand même elle a déjà ici sur le
territoire intervient dans les
entreprises avec des formations
gratuites pour former les salariés aux
bonnes pratiques
ça vous le disiez il ya déjà plus rien
déjà déjà certaines pratiques de
responsabilité individuelle faisons
attention a pas donné
qu'ils ne servent à rien juste informé
les des escrocs et c'est pas mal de les
mobiliser effectivement de les faire
venir en entreprise pour au moins avoir
un ensemble de règles de base ça me fait
penser que la gendarmerie des yvelines
il propose aussi une fois ils ont fait
une matinée il me semble au golf
national
sur forme et justement les les pme les
tpe les dirigeants de ces deux
entreprises pour faire face justement à
des eaux danger sur le numérique
voilà bon on pourrait continuer
longtemps parce qu'il vous trouve bien
on aura l'occasion de se retrouver au
cours de l'année merci infiniment vers
les objectifs élevés je rappelle le
titre de votre livre stratégie
e-marketing
et puis merci beaucoup des coloris et
bonne année merci à
vous tous voilà j'espère que ce numéro
spécial de paf vous a plu en tout cas on
essayé d'aborder de feuilleter déjà par
avance l'album de 2022 merci à tous
[Musique]